find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result
covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with hospital 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020
nashville 4
this public body is authorized to be
electronified
this is a work session on revenues
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order and confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaries during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
like.state.nh.us in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting
assisting us jennifer four committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote
i start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance
when each member states that president
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law so representative bernstein
would you take the role
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you today is may the 12th
2021 it is 10 02 a.m we'll begin roll
call with representative
patrick o'brian here at my home in
stratham my wife's in the house zooming
on as a member of the
aging commission that she's on thank you
uh representative mary griffin
representative jordan owerry
allman hudson my wife is in the house
someplace and
i'm just sitting here trying to figure
out how come i didn't get any
check from elwood we were all wondering
that
actually um representative ober good
morning
holmen hudson with the usual group of
six
good representative doucette
your clerk is alan berschke and i'm in
my home office in nottingham new
hampshire by myself
representative robert elliott i'm here
in my daughter's home
uh in salem new hampshire she's a
pharmacist she works a 12
hour shift for the next five days and
it's a horror show
thank you very much good morning
representative jeanine
representative nunes good morning mr
clerk it's a beautiful day in pelham new
hampshire where i'm home alone
glad to hear that good morning to you
sir representative tim baxter
it looks like tim's screen is frozen
right now we'll come back to
representative baxter representative
spillsbury
good morning i'm home in charlestown
with my wife elsewhere in the home
representative hey mr clerk yes sir mr
clerk
sorry i think my connection was cutting
out there but i'm i'm here in my car i
apologize about the connection
no problem good morning to you
representative baxter representative
tudor
here in northwood uh wife and grandkids
upstairs
i'm back in the basement representative
susan
i'm alone in lebanon thank you senator
james
i'm here alone in my home office and
jeffrey
representative southward here alone in
dover
representative malloy uh here alone in
greenland
representative thomas c schamberg
representative schamberg is here in
wilmette and this is the best part of
the day listening to your tenor voice
call out our names thank you you're too
kind representative
representative tucker i'm here alone
in randolph where it snowed at about
2500 feet
and above so the mountains are quite
beautiful
very good representative gomarlo i'm
here in swansea
alone representative laughman
representative gorg good morning i am
present and alone
good morning representative hacken
phillips good morning i
am alone from my home in hanover with
the two dogs today
representative james murphy uh good
morning i am home alone in hanover
our chairman representative norman major
good morning i'm home
home in my office in plasto and my wife
is in the house good morning sir
uh mr chair there are 20 members present
four are unable to be here right now
thank you representative bernstein
this morning we're going to deal with
revenues and primarily the
revenues associated we need to
we're going to be discussing senate bill
3.
janine would you let any members of the
dra yes i
will
so that would be melissa rollins and
uh devon rodrick
unless there's someone else i don't know
okay one more
melissa who do you have with you
good morning representative major
we have carolyn lear assistant
commissioner of department of revenue
as well as devon rupp financial analyst
of the department of revenue and myself
melissa roland senior financial analyst
for department of revenue
yesterday representative romney and
myself
talked with the dra relative to
the revenue is associated with senate
bill three
and we wanted to get a better idea of
the revenues associated with ppp funds
and the revenues associated
with the other
stimulus packages in order to be able to
determine
which are potential candidates for
refunding in the future
if if we pass senate bill 3
and also which are the ones associated
with
the additional stimulus packages
so that they
the bulk of that might be considered as
one-time revenue
so melissa
[Music]
melissa or carolyn would you be able to
get us started on this
see i'm muted i'm sorry um i can kick us
off
i think i'll start um with
um your question about the impact of
ppp um first
and to begin i just want to um
sort of step back for a minute
and talk about what we are
seeing and what we expect to see
for tax revenue
under current law as it relates
to forgiven tpp loans
um so as you'll recall when commissioner
stepp
um initially testified on this bill
under current law for given ppp
loans are included in
revenue as taxable income
but to the extent that ppp loan is used
to pay for business expenses
it also is a deduction so for the most
part
what we expect to see under
current law is no real impact
on revenue from forgiven ppp loans
because it's our belief
and i think you've heard testimony to
confirm that
that based on the economic conditions as
well as the terms of the ppp
program most ppp money
was spent on normal business expenses
so they'll include the revenue and
income but then they'll deduct it all
out again to account for those expenses
and that's really reflected in what we
see in
on returns to date
so we queried um returns
received to date and taxpayers have
reported about 5.4 million
in ppp revenue and what they're
reporting to us
is that portion of forgiven ppp loan
that they did not
spend on deductible expenses so that
number is very small
and that's what we would expect to see
because
our expectation is that businesses used
that money
for um for business expenses
um however because
we have such a large number of
extensions
um this year we are also
missing a lot of data so we think that
that
5.4 million relates to
about 8 of the total number
of forms that we
um expected to receive for
calendar year 2020 tax filers those
returns won't come in
until the fall um so there is sort of a
lack of data
for us to affirmatively say
that the revenue we've received to date
attributable to ppp is small
the fiscal impact of senate bill 3
is less about losing revenue
we expected to receive and is
more about allowing
expenses um when you're not
requiring the taxpayer to also recognize
the income
that was used to pay those expenses
so the fiscal impact of sb3 is really
the fact that you under senate bill 3
you would you would not include the
forgiven ppp loan in income
but you would still allow that expense
and then that expense because it's not
offsetting
the ppp for given loan is going to
offset
otherwise taxable income of that
taxpayer
um you have
the fiscal impact of of that
um that that policy decision
um all in it's about 100 million dollars
and we're working now to do our best to
come up with
um a meaningful methodology for
um trying to spread that out acro across
fiscal years
um so that if you do proceed with senate
bill 3 you'll have a better sense of how
to account for it
um probably there it makes sense for me
to pause and answer any questions
questions from the members of
representative romney
representative rodney are you muted
there thank you mr chair is there a um
issue with the timing of
when they take the deduction
for expense and the versus
taking uh for the forgiven revenue is
not taxable
is that an issue i mean can they take
can they take the deduction for the for
the expense
before a tax year
before uh the loan is forgiven when the
loan is forgiven
then they they can take the
the uh reduce the the revenue by the
amount of the forgiven
revenue follow i'm saying
so yes i i do understand and i think
our expectation um
is that taxpayers reported
those expenses which under current law
are deductible in um
in the calendar year that they were
incurred so they should have for
calendar year file or should have been
reported in calendar year
2020 um they would have
included the expenses um but
presumably not included the revenue
until
actually forgiven um what we know
is that um and i think what you heard
from the cpas
is i think taxpayers have been taking
different positions
on this issue there was some irs
guidance
um that indicated that taxpayers should
treat um a
ppp loan as forgiven if they
reasonably expected
that loan to be forgiven even if it
hadn't yet been forgiven yet
and so in some instances i believe
taxpayers did follow that treatment
for new hampshire purposes and did
report both the expenses
and the income on their 2020 return when
they filed it
but as you heard from the cpas they at
least some of them have advised
their clients to not count the people
the forgiveness
loan until actually forgiven um and in
that instance there would be a
disconnect
between the expenses and um
the revenue
the taxpayers had
if they had an expectation that they
would be forgiven
would report in their federal taxes
that it is forgiven but
it never had any instructions relative
to
the state tax is that correct that's
correct and i think that's why there's
probably a disconnect
with um what we thought we were going to
see because generally our expectation
is that on timing issues like that
taxpayers follow the feds
um but i think you're absolutely right
there was no directive from us
to follow that federal guidance
and from what i hear from accountants
they uh recommended
to file using current law rather than
some as assuming such as the other fed
said that
you could assume you're gonna get it
okay and so unfortunately that
that disconnect and that different
treatment among
taxpayers and cpas unfortunately makes
the situation more uncertain
as it relates to that timing question
caused more confusion
representatives
thank you had to get to my mute button
um so this is really hard to
get a handle on um the
situation where a taxpayer
in fiscal year 20 takes
has taken a deduction for the expenses
that
related to the ppp loan
and subsequently in a subsequent tax
year
receives forgiveness on the loan
what i'm wondering about is is this
what will that and all the other
taxpayers like that
um do
uh will they will they be seeking a
refund
um how does this go
the deduction that they took
um we'll still be allowed
so yep yeah
so if a taxpayer both
um under current law
took the deduction and paid the tax
in calendar year 2020 um
that would result in a refund
if senate bill 3 was passed
if a taxpayer took the deduction
in 2020 but doesn't
wouldn't claim the income until the loan
is actually forgiven in a later year
that will result
in a decrease in expected revenue
okay well i'll leave it there for now
other questions at this point
uh representative romney yeah i guess
because and sp3
both the the the
expense can be deducted in both cases
yeah
that's the issue it's it's the revenue
part
the forgiveness part of the revenue so
that's where i see the timing issue
that one can happen without the other
and i guess there's no clear answer on
on it other
understand that that's the case and the
degree to which that happens
it depends on how people are filing i
guess is that correct
that's exactly right representative
thank you
in that case they could file an amended
return
or declare
less taxes owed in their fy 2021
tax i would assume if sv3 is
passed you will have both refunds
and just taxpayers paying less
depending on what they did in their 2020
year
representative spellsbury thank you mr
chairman
um as i understand
the position being taken by
accountants and clients advocating sp3
it tends to center i think on the
a situation where they have reported
expenses
in 2020. they they already
feel like they've whether they've
reported or not they've
made their estimated payments and
they've done their accounting for the
2020 liability
if there was any and now they're
concerned that the forgiveness will
occur in 21
and that if we don't pass sb3
it's going to create a cash um
flow uh
difficulty uh because they
you know they've said repeatedly it
didn't set
cash aside they spent all of the money
that came from ppp
on expenses now i'm actually i'm having
a hard time really
taking the argument very seriously i see
i see this
the timing issue but are there
provisions
in our current uh business profits tax
which i don't know
intimately that allows them to
carry forward uh excess losses from one
year
uh to the next year so that any uh
income that is not recognized until
forgiven in 21
can be offset with losses
that were not fully absorbed in 20
or if if that is not currently possible
could we further tweak our amendment
by allowing on the basis of the pandemic
having
lasted for more than a year and having
carried over two different tax years
a one-time provision that just says
any expenses or losses incurred in 20
can be offset against income generated
in 21.
simple loss carry forward
that's exactly right representative so i
melissa can jump in if i'm
getting it wrong but i believe new
hampshire allows the carry forward of
prior year losses for 10 years
so that would certainly capture um
an instance where the taxpayer deducted
expenses um in 2020
to the extent
well thank you for clarifying that that
that means we don't even need
to further change the bill or the
amendment
um and i've gone back
and very carefully re-read
each letter that i've received from a
business taxpayer and accountant
and i honestly i read closely
i don't think their argument is sound at
all
and when i carefully
parse what's being said in
the mason and rich letter and the
various other letters we've received
they just don't hold water and if if the
if the idea is that it uh
that it's an anomaly of timing i think
that the tax loss carry forward
completely
resolves that
any comment on that uh carolyn
it's not no
representative murphy thank you mr
chairman just a point of clarification
carolyn
is it right that most of the businesses
declared the
expense uh deduction in 20
but they had the option of filing
the ppp dollars as income either in 20
or in 21 they could do it either year is
that correct
we would have accepted it we would have
accepted
the taxpayers decision to report
ppp loans in both 20 or 21
um based on that irs guidance telling
them to treat
the loan as forgiven even if not yet
technically forgiven
so yes the answer to your question is
yes so
just yeah i was just wondering also do
you know and i've heard from some
businesses up here that they receive
the ppp dollars
as a loan um and then maybe forgiven
but they felt that there were changes
made by congress and the feds and
they decided to return the dollars
basically do you know the magnitude of
businesses that have returned to dollars
i do not know that representative okay
good question
further questions before the dra
continues
i don't see anything so the melissa or
carolyn so i think the other
question that you were hoping that we
would address
a bit is um this
concept of the 175 million that were
currently over
planned and how much of that
is attributable just more generally to
all of the various
stimulus programs are you ready for me
to move on to that
yes that would be very helpful to be
able to differentiate
you can't come up with exact numbers
but that 175 million dollars
uh that's there
could be is to me is made up of two
things
is the ppp loans once they're forgiven
we're going to have to be sent back as
refunds
and the other is the other stimulus
things that stimulated the economy
generated profits
of a one time nature because once the
pandemic is over it's not going to be
there again
so of that 175 what percentage of that
would be considered one-time money
can i just interject norm before
can i just interject first for a second
go ahead
uh when we say when we say 175 it's
really the 175 minus the 18 correct
yes so it's more like uh 157 we're
talking about
correct right and
that could grow the idea here is
is the process and
it's there's also of the 175 not only
is it the uh the 18 point sometime
but the normal growth
that you would anticipate
that would need to be taken out
and what remains is associated with ppp
loans
and the other stimulus packages that
would be considered at one time
so um
those of you who um
listen to us talk about revenues and
estimating revenues
have definitely heard us talk before
about the concept
of removing anomalies from the
the tax base before trying to predict
you know subsequent year revenues and i
think the real
struggle with fiscal year 2021
is going to be that you have
many anomalies and two really big
anomalies
you have the um
anomaly of the pandemic itself right
the the pandemic certainly reduced
revenues um in an
anomalous fashion during fiscal year
and at the same time you have the
stimulus
and its impacts on revenues which
anomalously impacts revenues in the
opposite direction
um you know the stimulus was really
meant to offset
the anomalous impact
of covid on the economy and so the
challenge becomes um how would you
adjust the fiscal year 21
base to account for both that negative
anomaly
and the positive anomaly or do you just
assume that they sort of cancel each
other out
and use fiscal year 21 as your base
from a data-driven standpoint
you know the department doesn't have a
lot of
data to sort of
really suss out the competing effects of
those
two anomalies on fiscal year 21 revenue
um you know certainly all of the
stimulus money
that has flowed into the economy in the
form of you know
grants to businesses and
enhanced unemployment benefits and you
know the direct
to individual stimulus payments from the
irs
all of those things flowing into the
economy have
certainly caused business taxes to be
higher than they would have been
if those stimulus programs hadn't
existed
but by how much um
you know we've thought on that question
and i'm not really sure
we have data to give you a figure
of how much of that 175 million
can really be attributable to
you know the massive amount of stimulus
money that's flowed into the economy
i think that's also compounded you know
our lack of information is also
compounded by the fact
that um most of our taxpayers
and certainly most of our largest
taxpayers
elect to file on extension so at this
point in the year
we have presumably all their money
but no information about what that money
means
we won't have the information about what
that money means
until they actually file their returns
in
october and november of this year um so
that certainly exacerbates
um your challenge and our challenge
in trying to figure out you know any
helpful information about that 175
million dollars that we are above or to
representative abrami's point really 155
million that were above
um planned this year and then
just to finish i'd add to that um
there are a lot of tax law changes
that are taking place this year as well
i mean i think a good example is that um
irc conformity last year
was really first year that we were all
in on internal revenue code conformity
to the um tax cuts and jobs act and we
estimated the amount of revenue we
thought conformity would generate
um it could we could have been wrong we
could have been
low and so some of that revenue could be
attributable to internal revenue code
conformity
again we won't know until we get all the
returns in
and then this is the first year of
market-based sourcing this year
which is a huge unknown as it relates to
revenue so certainly
estimate payments that we've received to
date this year
could be impacted by market-based
sourcing
being new with that
i think i'll pause give melissa the
opportunity to jump in if she has
anything to add or otherwise we can
field some questions
no carolyn i think you did a great job
covering that
questions at this point representative
romney and followed by representative
alani
um can you give us a sense of uh
how you brought up market-based sourcing
and this is the first year
of how we're doing finding those
companies that are service companies
providing
service to new hampshire that we can tax
that was the big issue when we talked
about market-based sourcing
how long would it take for us to
identify businesses
that don't volunteer to pay the tax to
new hampshire versus the other way
around
great question so at this point mark
market-based sourcing
took effect on 1-1 20-21
so the only thing we would have expected
to receive
to date is one quarterly estimate
payment
from calendar year filers um
i'm sorry um and so at this point
you're really in a voluntary compliance
position
we won't start our investigatory work
and our audit work really until we don't
receive returns next spring and fall
that's really the timing of our
compliance activity what we've received
to date will just be those
taxpayers that have voluntarily complied
okay thank you representative
thank you mr chairman uh
[Music]
i've got two
areas here of question on
one of them is that we heard from
uh ryan gottlobe
that and the uh employment security
analyses that on
there were higher there was more
more wage uh
total wages in this state
on during covid
then on
at least as we went along in covid
than there had been before even though
there were considerably less people
employed
because the low-wage people were thrown
out of the labor force they were mostly
on doing personal service and
couldn't do it they were shut down
and the high income people continued
to work and to get on
get raises and
i'm wondering on i don't think that
ends up meaning that there was more bet
than we would normally expect
uh that it would just be a small amount
of increase on the bt side and that most
of this
157 or whatever it was million
on is profit rather than
then wages than things that we tax in
bet
have you thought about those that
melissa do you have any thoughts on that
um i was trying to see if i had this
split between
vet and pbt um
for this month but i do think there's a
couple of things there at representative
ally i think you're right we have heard
that i was trying to go through um brian
gottlieb's presentation while you were
speaking
real quick because i do think
new hampshire i think there's a couple
of things that we've heard from
economists that
high wage earners have earned more
income
than they have like you stated however
low income earners have had severely
reduced
incomes um from employers than they had
how much those offset each other i'm not
entirely sure
if it is the higher earner incomes then
we would have more of a bet
of that increase depending on which
businesses you're talking about as well
so if they're smaller businesses we may
not see it as much in bed
compared to larger businesses
that are in the state but we can
definitely
drill into that a little bit more and as
carolyn said
the thing that we're struggling with
right now is that we have
a record number of extensions filed
compared historically
so what we have for data is so
minimal compared to what we have had in
the past
so we can take a sample of of
compensation on the bet return and see
if we've seen an
increase in that for the returns that
have been filed
however i'm not sure of how much of a
picture that will represent the whole
once we get all the returns in in
october
in november
i asked to wait my secondary until after
other people have talked
one of the things is you need
a heck of a lot of wages increase
in order to compete against what you
were getting in the business profits tax
because a million dollars every million
dollars extra
wages just generates
six thousand dollars of det so
if you had a hundred million dollars of
wages
talking about
six hundred thousand dollars
it's it's very hard
to really equate one against the other
but go ahead um you want to hold your
next question
so then represent ames
thank you um i think
that you uh dra were um
looking into the composition of the uh
the money that's come in in terms of
taxpayer types of taxpayers
and size i'm wondering if you have
made any progress with that
melissa would you like to speak to what
you have thus far i can see you looking
for it
sorry i was i was pulling it up as we
spoke um
so yes uh representatives we did have
your email it took a little bit longer
to dig in
only because when returning reporting
extension payments we don't necessarily
break down combined filers versus
corporations
so you think you had asked us to look at
extension payments that had come in
based on the top two tiers of the
triangle
so for those that are not completely
familiar with our triangles
the top two tiers equal um taxpayers
with a hundred thousand dollars
or greater of tax liability so we were
looking at of the extension payments how
many
how much of those came in for the top
two tiered um
amounts in the triangles as well as how
much
of the extensions were made up for
combined filers or water
water zip edge filers so for
extension payments for march and april
we got about 197.4 million
in revenue in those two voucher form
payments
um about 49 just under 50
of those were from combined filers and
that's based on their 2019 filing
so 97.2 million out of the 197.4 million
were combined fathers which are
typically
our larger corporate uh our larger
corporations and our larger filers
and then comparing that extension data
to those top two tiers of the triangles
again 100 000 or more
in bpt i should specify um that was
about
40 or 78.3 of the extension payments
coming
in were paid by taxpayers
in that that either the bottom half or
the
the lower two tiers um of the
of the triangle can you send us those
statistics
sure i think we have an email that will
go out today
thank you appreciate that is there
anything uh that you would say that
uh um you've learned from this
that that maybe uh
tells a story about changes in revenues
that's a good question i wish more
people filed on returns
than extensions just to throw that out
there um
we like data here so we like to dig in
and find it and it's really
because this is i know we say word again
unprecedented times
and modeling out revenues is definitely
challenging in this environment
and looking at an extension for those of
you who have not filed an extension it's
literally a piece of paper with a number
on it
with no information um
and they're so much higher than they
ever have been so
i don't think we have necessarily
gleaned anything off of them
that we would like to see typically in
march and april which is unfortunate
because
we also would like to know where this
money is coming from and
and how the breakdown is and have less
assumptions than
we're having to make but again it's hard
when you've never been through this
before
and trying to figure out what the future
brings uh
if i may just one other question
just with respect to say the
combined number 49
um is that substantially different or
roughly the same i don't have
your historical reports in front of me
and similarly for the top two tiers of
the triangle
are there changes uh relative to what
we've
always seen in the past it's a great
question
i don't have the information on that
this is the first time that we've
actually
dug into extensions and broke it out
between combined filers and corporate
corporations so we haven't done this in
prior years
however we can but when i do that i
would probably look at returns and
extensions because right now
extensions again are so far ahead
of returns you really can't compare it
well you can't compare it to 20 because
of the due date change but you'd have to
compare it to 19
and the extensions didn't look like they
did versus count
so um i think we could drill into that a
little bit more right now i don't i
don't have a comparison factor on that
well i i i'd encourage the drilling and
i understand the caveats and the caution
too yeah
thank you as a follow-up to his question
can you give us an appreciation of
compare it against 19
the number of additional extensions
and the magnitude compared to 19.
sure i actually have that let me just
just flip through my sheet here right
here and then provide that in your email
too
so extensions compared to 2019 dollar
wise we're up 51
um in count wise
i believe they are up 20 almost 20
percent
okay and then the follow-up question to
that
is that normal compared to
going back five years prior to
19 a year a year
um i don't have data on that but my gut
instinct is is
yes um i know looking back just
generally based on our accounts document
we've never seen extensions this high
the count of um um
nor the dollar amount in them thank you
representative elmi do you have your
second question
thank you yes on
i'm trying to look at all of these
individual stimulus payments that people
got
the lower income people would have just
been replacing
debts that that they normally paid
on time on paying their rent
paying for for their electric bills and
and um gasoline and all that kind of
thing
but beyond that some a lot of people
apparently were putting money
into savings
and then they were buying a lot of stuff
and apparently most of the stuff
i was from outside the state and
came through amazon
so it would have been all sorts of
companies um
and some of it was our local grocery
stores and stuff but they probably
weren't buying
much more than they would have if there
hadn't been coven
so um i don't know
what else they would have been spending
money on but have you got any thoughts
about on whether any of this
activity would have actually
materially changed changed our revenue
sources
that well there's liquor
and that's not the only one i can think
of because the tobacco is basically from
massachusetts
um is there any of that that we actually
end up taxing indirectly
so i think that's really the the
conundrum that i was trying to talk
about
earlier is you know
the the the covet pandemic
in isolation would have substantially
reduced
revenues um and so
therefore the stimulus
in some respects simply brought us
up to where we would have been had the
pandemic not
happen i think the question that
representative major is
trying to identify is did it lift it up
lift us up higher than where we would
have been
and i don't know how we in a data driven
way
really give you that answer
um just because of the amount of detail
that we get
doesn't really say is this a dollar that
would have been spent
had covid not happen
but the extensive buying of stuff that i
understand happened and most of it
remotely
i don't think we've got anything in our
tax system
that would pick that up at this point
i think i can tell you anecdotally
without disclosing taxpayer information
that you know big box stores
performed really well um retail
generally what we know anecdotally to be
retail
um type taxpayers
performed well last year
um to me that is evidence that some of
that spending
was um more than just
replacing what they lost due to covid
you all representing me
um as much as i can be okay uh
representative romney followed by
representative spillsbury
this wasn't going to be thank you mr
chair this wasn't going to be my comment
but i will comment
if you were trying to build a pool last
summer an
in-ground pool you had like a two-year
waiting list in new hampshire
uh people are spending money that they
normally would spend on going on
vacation and stuff like that is we
we heard all sorts of stories about
those kind of things but
for um carolyn and
melissa um you may want to just share
some stories from the other states that
so that the committee can appreciate
that we don't stand alone in terms of
kind of uh kind of wandering in the dark
here a little bit
uh trying to estimate uh future revenues
you want to share some of those stories
from other states or
one whatever yeah sure um i want to
pause one second though because i
realized they pulled the
wrong documents so it happens when
you're going on the fly for extensions
if i can just update my numbers i
i give you mid month numbers not end of
the month dollars were up 63 percent
compared to 19
and counts were up 48 percent compared
i knew that never seen below when i
spent it
before we finished this session
i'd like to hear from the dra you don't
need to answer now
all the information that you have at
this point in time
your revenue estimates for fy 22 and 23
have you come up with new revenue
estimates
and then if they're not specific it's a
a new range so i'll go to representative
spillsbury
i had my uh mr chair
a chance to react to my question
yes thank you representative of brahmin
um sorry i sidetracked there for a
moment
uh so yeah so compared to other states
i'm waiting for another report
we get um that sort of comes in to see
how other states are doing we just got
it from march but i don't think march is
the whole picture as we know april just
came in really strong
and the march report that does compare
other states revenues
showed some states have some pretty good
winners in the corporate tax department
and some have losers
anecdotally speaking about april which
was was sort of uh
a big change compared to march march um
we had some growth but not what we had
compared to april
i do know um there are states that are
doing really well um
for instance we've we've been chatting
with california a bit
um for our sb3 because they have a
similar bill out there
that we just like to get some impact uh
input back and forth to make sure we're
sort of on the right track
and we were just chatting somebody
someone in the same similar position
and they're typically they have a much
larger revenue source for their
corporate income tax compared to ours
they're normally a few maybe a few
hundred million ahead of plan and
currently right now they're a billion
dollars
plus ahead of their plan and they're
sort of in the same situation that
revenue is definitely
um flowing in so we are hearing that
from other states again
when we get the report for april it will
be more definitive numbers and answers
versus anecdotally
um but there are other states that are
faring well
there are other states that are not
doing as well i think new york isn't
doing as well
but it it we're not alone in this
thank you since you mentioned
california didn't california come up
with an
estimate of what it would cost them if
they
forgave the ppp loans
it was around 6.2 billion dollars
yeah that's huge
it's a big state it's a big state
and like we really need to compare what
the total revenue
business tax revenue would be compared
to
and ourselves get an idea for a big
state
that conforms with the feds on the
ppp whether on
how much increase they've seen in
revenues
are you asking a state that conformed
um sort of automatically so it should
have been baked in
we can take a look at that and see if we
can
find anything useful
any more information on other states
if not then we can go to representative
spillsbury
followed by also us
thank you mr chairman just before i
asked uh my question
uh another point on california is that
yesterday there were headlines
indicating their
state revenue surplus is great enough
that they're thinking of sending
uh payments out to their
taxpayers similar to the ones that have
been sent out in three stages by the
feds
um i i guess i'm going to
try and formulate this is a question
that
lacking data we have to make a lot of
assumptions we look around for anecdotal
stories
and it seems to me that uh
what we see in net on on 2020 is a
great skewing of outcomes
and unfortunately a lot of times
governmental actions have the tendency
of pushing
separations even further than they were
before so the poor get poorer and the
rich get richer
and so you know following up on a couple
of comments that
uh representative olany made
it seems like there were an awful lot of
low-income
high-touch service workers who were very
badly hurt
and maybe many of the businesses that
employ that kind of worker
like in the uh
hospitality and tourism and restaurants
were the ones that were most harmed and
then there were many other sectors that
did
better than normal i was going to use
the pool analogy also
representative rami but you name it when
it comes to backyard
entertainment um i've never seen
so much chatter on our community forum
about about where can i get
uh trampolines and uh uh
grills and all kinds of other stuff to
be used at home
trying to get tradesmen to do anything
uh was difficult home depot was doing an
incredible business with home
improvement stuff
renovations and
so we've already had comments about big
box stores and internet purchases
and businesses that switched production
to support ppp
uh an enormous a number of employees who
were
offered bonuses to stay on
or hardship pay including teachers
i just wonder whether net net
when the stories and the date is all in
in two three years and we look
back we might actually find that there
was on that
increased economic activity in
2020 and we see it in our own tax
revenues on the one side we see
that the meals and rooms tax down
but we see the tobacco the liquor the
real estate transfer tax all up so this
skilling is occurring in so many ways we
can't keep track of it but it doesn't
necessarily
mean that total net income was down and
total net economic activity was down
from a state perspective our revenues
ride on total net activity
so would you agree that's the question
i think the answer has to be yes um
because the numbers
the numbers are the numbers
hard to gauge
it's a nice review of representative
hillsboro spillsberry
uh representing software
thank you mr chairman an anecdote and
then i want to follow up on
representative spillsberry um
i did decide to buy a new oven this
winter because i was doing more cooking
and my local appliance store generations
running it
um at a great small business said this
has been their best year ever
and they were way backed up with all
kinds of appliances and i think
that's just one more example and my
follow-up
uh goes along with um representative
spillsberry
there were many people who got up to 3
000 in stimulus funds
who did not have any financial need and
i really think that
those extra checks coming in to really
middle-income people
throughout new hampshire i think then
they thought about what is something
i've always wanted to get
but again following up on the
representative i do think a lot of that
money
may be summoned to savings but i think a
lot of it did flow into the new
hampshire economy
yeah i think that's a fair statement i
think i'd give you another example i
mean
think about um student loan the
suspension of payments on
federal student loans that's sort of a
below the radar item but think about the
impact
of potentially not having to make your
student loan payments over the last
over a year now um and what
would what potentially folks did with
the that dollar
because the decision was agnostic to
whether or not
the borrower um needed
to have their suspend their payment
suspended it was
just suspended even things as simple as
that and as
discrete as that could certainly have
had an
impact on consumer spending saving
all of those things that directly feed
the economy
yeah and i think just um to add to that
economically what we've heard from
economists are that
although spending was great it was still
stalled some
and this is what it looked like and
there is a pretty good pent-up demand
for spending that they anticipate seeing
in this next coming year
and i think couple that with
representative southworth who spoke
about the spending and then maybe some
in savings i think what we've also heard
is that savings
personal savings accounts are at an
all-time high as well
so it's almost a split of there was
increased spending
but maybe not even at the peak of what
it could have been
coupled with people were putting funds
away
so it's not a total loss at the end of
this year
okay i've got a question to ask the dre
is that with the release
of the american recovery act funds
and then they've just recently released
the rules even though we don't have them
in place yet or
all right we will be getting somebody to
come in and
help us understand what the rules are
going to be what do you anticipate
these american recovery act funds
are going to do to our revenues
this coming year
have you done any work on this yet
we haven't done any um any
actual estimates i think it would
because
so much of the money is going to flow to
the state and it's going to be a state
level decision
on how to use it i think it will depend
a bit
on what new hampshire and all the other
states decide to do with that money
but i think it's safe to say that to the
extent the programs mirror what was
um distributed in the first rounds
of stimulus through the cares act i
think you would
we would anticipate seeing a similar
impact um as we saw in fiscal
21 from those funds because it sure is
going to
affect our overall revenue picture but
nobody understands
how it's fun so
we need to get revenues out and agree on
revenues for the senate
by the time we do our committee of
conference and i don't think we'll have
the answers complete at that point in
time
have you adjusted your revenue estimates
for fy 2223 at this point in time or are
you
are you waiting for
more information on the american
recovery act
or what
go ahead melissa um we
have since we presented to you last
we dug into april and revised our fiscal
year 21
numbers um as for our 22
and 23 um we have not made any
additional adjustments from when we
presented to you
um i believe it was a couple weeks ago
all right represent eleanor
thank you on is the dra
also responsible for trying to
understand the
um arpa guidance the
american rescue plan guide guidance that
just got
issued from the treasury and
specifically
on how it affects uh
whether or not um
if we keep all those tax cuts in the
budget
or we pass a bill that we just voted to
pass
yesterday that's much smaller uh
the sb 101 on
how on whether they would
trigger removing money in which years
great question yeah so i i printed it
yesterday
and killed a lot of trees and read it
so i did attempt to understand it but i
don't think that the department will be
the
agency that will officially weigh in on
that question i really think
that that will be the department of
justice
um or gopher probably gopher with you
know the advice
of the department of justice since
gopher is the agency that will
ultimately be responsible
for spending the vast majority of those
arpa funds
or at least that's my understanding i
don't have any inside
knowledge on that if i
could we never got hardly any
information out of gopher and we never
saw them
and this is really important to our
committee i wonder
are we going i i distributed to
everybody after representative ames told
us that
uh there was a larger document than the
one i'd found
on last night i distributed to everybody
the pages that deal
with uh net tax revenue reductions
which is only about 20 pages uh 15
i think so but it is extremely dense so
i haven't
started to read it yet because i was too
tired
last night and
on i think especially the timing issues
of when the money
comes in when its growth is calculated
from all that
i hope it's in there but we need to
understand it
and i'm sure there's going to be
additional
publications on interpreting
how to spend these funds and
how you can get in trouble and not get
in trouble
and that will come come with time
but we only have to let 20 till early
june
represents
thank you um yeah i just want to second
uh the thought advanced by
representative army
um that it's important that
we understand the process for
[Music]
identifying the information that's
responsive to the treasury's guidance
in a way that we all feel comfortable
with because it's going to be
absolutely critical and it starts with
[Music]
the sort of baseline year that
the guidance points towards which they
call fiscal year 2019
representative alameda yesterday uh
wondered what fiscal year means in that
context
is is the same as ours or not i
kind of think it's not the same i think
it's the federal fiscal year
which is which way do you go october to
september or september to october which
ever
um and um
if that's the case there's going to have
to be some jiggering with
our numbers to square them with that
baseline and then there's a lot of
figuring that goes in
as time passes um
and i'd certainly like to see a process
that goes beyond
the process that the governor set up
with the gopher
system and i hope that
let's say the legislative powers that be
are focused on this
while there's still time to to address
this
next week tuesday
we'll be dealing with a web session on
senate bill
22 and senate bill three
we'll also be having executive sessions
on wednesday i hope to have somebody to
come in that
understands what the rules are relative
to
the american recovery act what can
how it can be spent and and what not to
spend it on
to so it doesn't jeopardize
these funds
that's what we're planning for next week
any further questions for today
representative salzburg
thank you mr chairman uh the questions
for you
let's say we do pass a budget in june
and if that happens there are major
changes that
we discover in the summer fall whether
it's the rules uh
different funds and so on what is the
process from there on
is there something typical the way they
handle something that's pretty unique
like that
that's the same question i have and that
would have to be worked out with the
senate president
and the speaker to see
what the strategy would be yeah and this
strategy could very well be is to come
in
and have another session yes okay
thank you a new budget
yeah this is a unique year so it just
seems like you know
uh creativity is needed and
i'm sure you're going to see that
representative i'm followed by
representative brown here
i think representative brownlee was from
representative romney thank you uh mr
chair
so i just want to are we going to cover
uh
the preliminary thoughts of the dra
today as
it goes to how the if we do pass sb3
the spread of the impact over the next a
bunch of fiscal years
that we all will not hit in one fiscal
year the 99.4 million
right um as a matter of fact
we we have discussed that you and i have
with the dra so maybe the dra might want
to
explain how
the sp3 would fall out
over the fiscal years how much of it
would
show up in fy 21
and then 22 23 and 24.
yeah after so when we chatted um we
on monday representative abrami what we
had done is
taken a look at really california's
methodology
in their you know fiscal note equivalent
for their senate bill 3
bill um and
they had determined that you know the
bulk of the impact
was in fiscal 22 maybe as much as 50
about a quarter of the impact in 23 and
then the rest in out years
um but california is different than new
hampshire and
a couple of important ways including the
fact that
they tax partnerships and llcs very
different than new hampshire does
at the individual level instead of at
the entity level
as well as some of the certain
parameters that they put on their
own decision to conform um to the
federal ppp
treatment so i think what i would like
to do
is and what we've we began doing
yesterday was
sort of coming up with a new hampshire
specific methodology
to make sure that we wouldn't differ
significantly from what
california predicted and we can talk to
you about that next
week if that is helpful but i think it's
fair to say
that the bulk of the impact we would
expect to be in fiscal 22
followed by 23 and then trailing impacts
in later years
that would be helpful by next week we
should know
uh what we will be doing on senate bill
3.
at this point we have not made a
decision on senate bill 3
thank you i just wanted to ask is the
only thing we're going to exact next
week
uh on sb
22 was it uh yeah
or are we going to possibly exec
sb3 at this point
it'll be sp22 sb3 is
up in the air
because uh well both uh
representative murphy and i have been
talking
with our very capable uh
chamber executive uh
for our region and on
i think that it really would be good to
get
some kind of of
uh input from the chambers
on the issues that a number of people in
the committee have brought up about
on which of these businesses actually
are barely surviving on this uh at this
point that god sp
got ppp loans and uh which ones
are thriving as some people have put it
well we could look at that next week too
we could bring in a chamber member
and hopefully
bia can identify
some of the businesses that are just
barely surviving and some that didn't
survive
the bia generally deals with big
businesses
it's the chambers that deal with the
smaller ones
well let's get together and work that
out
uh anything else today
we have our work ahead of us i think we
will be in a better position to know
what we'll be doing as 3 from next week
all right thank you
and pat would you give me a call